manuela se no
grazie
[Musica]
chiudere
si sentono tiri
[Musica]
un po come facciamo adesso stiamo peggio
mentre conosciuto
c'è stato un equivoco la cena si che voi
a doverla preparare
tradizione di fondi
[Applauso]
[Musica]
quindi non volevano che noi qui ci
massimo per loro quindi sei filippo sa
lo sa io sarò grande chef che ne pensate
facciamo una julio veloce che ne pensate
agli oli tipologia
mi son caduti in di dallo schifo
titolo gelate devo vip resto vediamo la
scheda creatura sui vampiri troviamo un
piccolo il vampiro il vampiro una
creatura sovrannaturale molto antico
particolarmente diffusa nell'europa
dell'est si nutre del fango degli esseri
umani e può trasformare le proprie
vittime
i nuovi vampiri mordendoli sul collo è
uno che come volevano trasformati in
nuovi bambini ecco perché il figlio mi
stavo sempre attaccato al collo evoca
voleva morto orme riconoscere questa
creatura può essere difficoltoso
ecco perché ci sembravano solo un po
strano all'inizio non avevano neanche i
denti perché un apparenza è simile a un
essere umano a parte i seguenti tratti
che tradiscono la sua vera natura
mostruosa ha la pelle molto chiara non
erano pallidi e non può esporsi alla
luce diretta del sole che lo ridurrebbe
in cenere
quindi forse questo può aiutarci ma
vediamo kodirova leggere a canini molto
lumi per succhiare il sangue non si
ripete negli specchi non invecchia
riposa solo nella propria bara e
sensibile alle luci troppo forti e non
sopporta l'odore dell'olio
ecco perché hanno reagito così quando
gli ho detto dellai olio magari facciamo
un arrabbiata
possiamo pasticciato
tifoso sono il tra noi
diamo
un'idea aspettiamo che sorga il sole
perché loro fanno dormire quando fa
quando sei l'uso è vero così all'alba
prova ok aspettiamo che non vadano a
dormire poi usciamo di qua e apriamo la
porta e scappiamo scappiamo si pesca non
resisto
ho bisogno di bere
sì per festeggiare sono rinchiusi in più
per i primi 20 non
li sa se per mimmo abbiamo tutti
l'importante adesso è che non ci
addormentiamo perché ho paura che se ci
addormentiamo loro ci vengano a prendere
un buon che non ho dubbi amore per
veglie accertare che che stia al banco
di loro dormiranno e non potremmo
scappare sono d'accordo con te che ci
addormentiamo no ma temiamo ci svegli ok
hai detto motoryacht is vedi perché
stavo dormendo bene possiamo andare a
dormire così posso mettere i miei canini
sotto il cuscino e durante il giorno il
pipistrello dei cimeli porterà via
sta per sorgere il sole
ios anno
sì sì è tempo di andare a dormire
dobbiamo resistere
dato dalla nostra casa non si può
fuggire sono in trappola si sono i tra
mola
[Musica]
ciao ragazzi
è l'alba
stanno correndo non lo so spero di sì i
bambini dormono di giorno quindi siccome
lampo ha probabilmente sono già andati a
dormire ora possiamo provare a scappare
si sentono dei rumori stiamo attenti non
facciamoci scoprire lasciate un mi piace
per portarci fortuna
[Musica]
ok misto che stanno tornando proprio a
mosca
[Musica]
come facciamo adesso ma domani abbiamo
il libro come scudo aspetta aspetta un
attimo magari hanno nascosto alla chiave
oppure ce l'hanno loro tipo appesa al
collo oppure al braccio o nelle tasche
dobbiamo dobbiamo controllarle magari ce
l'hanno loro ok cerchiamo la chiave
[Applauso]
no no non è stata ok passiamo al tar si
sta tornando comunque sauro
quello deve essere l'orsacchiotto degli
i vampiri si sta quindi kant
per fortuna dorme profondamente
sono chiave neanche cuore
controlliamo se il padre alla chiave
addosso
il fratellino la chiave
[Musica]
[Applauso]
però se ne stanno aprendo le gambe
capirono salvato la piuma testa ha dato
ma aveva la chiave addosso no ho
controllato non aveva nulla ok
controlliamo al padre per l'ultimo
rimasto
no
[Musica]
che sfortuna
ma sia chiaro
ci hanno chiusi a chiave qua dentro non
possiamo neanche scappare non sappiamo
dove la chiave come possiamo fare come
rivedere la scheda creatura specchiati
oppure le chiavi non ce l'avevano
addosso ma carino telecomando le porte
le finestre col telecomando può essere i
pompieri nel 1800 non avevano il
telecomando e sensibile ai russi sogno
non può esporsi alla luce diretta del
sole la luce diretta del sole all idea
siccome non riusciamo a scappare perché
siamo chiusi dentro possiamo aprire le
finestre e c'è scritto che loro si
riducono in genere alla luce diretta del
sole quindi se no io primo le finestre
che loro hanno oscurato il rose i
dottori colpiranno il loro si
trasformeranno in genere aspetta però è
ancora l'alba loro sono appena andati a
dormire dobbiamo aspettare che il sole
sia più alto da neanche un luce ok
aspettiamo
vediamo che 0 il nostro piano perché
erano mezzi addormentati aspettiamo che
il sole sia bello alto poi riusciamo
apriamo le finestre però non
addormentiamo c no no no no dormitio
così comando vediamo se dopo bricolo tra
siamo svegli programmi con gli stecchini
al un occhio così
non ne siamo così e mi piace
addormentiamo ormai siamo arrivati qui
mancano poche ore
al mattino io come tanti altri
guarda senza la luce del sole
dobbiamo uscire piano piano facciamo
silenzio si svegliano i bambini e
apriamo le finestre per far entrare la
luce del sole per l'ingegneria giusto
giusto giusto
si dobbiamo prendere 10 punti altrimenti
ci trasformeremo in creature dobbiamo
fare altrimenti svegliamo le creature e
bambini c'è più tempo per fare il piano
non abbiamo più tempo capisci murray per
esaurire il tempo però trasformato in
creature al servizio di berenice per
sempre diamoci trafiggere i bambini il
prima possibile lui c'è più tempo
andiamo piano è venuto aprire le
finestre st
così
definita iniziavo stiamo dopo la fine
proviamo ad aprire quella finestra far
entrare la luce e poi non solamente c'è
anche quell'altra la spezia iniziamo con
quel siena è più vicina
faccio un incantesimo alla carta provato
puritano il libro
[Musica]
non so
i lavori libro mi
sta succedendo
[Musica]
dobbiamo appena
sinistra
come finestra
che cosa è successo
una barriera si
aspetta proviamo con il libro prof
penso a frizzanti l'altra per noi
sarebbe la fine
di un modello
[Applauso]
[Musica]
li abbiamo presi si sono comparsi quale
libro sono i vetri sono quindi punti ma
ora ha detto abbiamo presto andiamo via
dalla casa mi va benissimo ma sappiamo
abbiamo sentito la maledizione di
berenice si
e poi avete lasciato mi piace e avete
già storie paura a grappolo di misteri
se non ce l'avete ancora andate a
prenderlo vi raccomando lasciate un mi
piace passato se volete che la nostra
avventura contini lui che altre prove si
aspetteranno proseguiamo e lo scopriremo
assieme
vedi vinto però so io
ma mi sono anche divertita ragazzi
siete convinti che il gioco finisca qui
poveri illusi ma non avete capito chi
sono io
[Musica]